hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from the final round of
the girls junior World Championship 2023
it is belava crasta of Bulgaria versus
Candela Bell and Francisco guuro of
Argentina and uh both of them have
reached this point in the championship
without losing a single game which is
absolutely incredible and uh although
you might expect a calm game because
this is board one this is the final
round it is anything but that because
Bellas laava is leading by a full point
so in in order for Candela to actually
win the world title H she has to defeat
bellava with the black pieces and this
is just
a an incredible top level game so let's
check it out Bosa has the white pieces
and she opens with Pawn to D4 both of
them are I think uh 17 years old um I
think Candela just uh um I think like a
month ago or something um uh turn 17 and
Bava is 17 or 18 uh not really sure and
um you have to be under 20 to
participate in this Championship
although you have some very very strong
young players like meu who is 13 but you
know you've seen what happened in the
previous game so let's see what happens
here D4 we have Knight to F6 C4 and now
Pawn to C5 as she needs a win Candela
goes for the benon defense and how do
you react to this of course if you if
your opponent is banking everything on
the Bon defense you know that they are
very well prepared for D5 so instead
lava goes for the anti benoni she
transposes into the English and this is
sort of the anti benoni line Knight F3 C
captures Knight captures and now uh
standard moves here are E5 kicking away
the Knight E6 maybe Knight to C6 but she
goes for Pawn to B6 a fairly rare move
but it has been played before for
example in 2010 Magnus Carlson played it
against yon Ludwick hammer and the
Magnus lost the game so yeah you have to
you know be very very careful here going
for the development of of the light
Square Bishop so early on in the game uh
Knight to C3 and now Bishop to B7 we
have Pawn to F3 limiting the power of
the light Square bishop and now Pawn to
e uh sorry E6 first and pawn to E4 D6
and Bishop to E2 so we have Pawn to A6
uh and now okay you could Castle but
here we have Bishop to E3 and now Knight
B to D7 we have castles and Bishop D7 so
both of them just playing nice
developing moves we have Rook to C1 uh
and castles we have PA Pawn to A3 and
here again it's a very wellknown
position been reached many times for
example Yan pomi had this position
against Gat kamsky in the Russian team
championship for men in 2015 and uh that
game ended in a draw where kamsky
continued with Rook to C8 Rook to C8
being the top engine move even today uh
but here we have Queen to C7 she goes
for a bit of a different approach um
Cela wants to play Rook to C8 and then
REM maneuver the queen over to B8 so
okay Pawn to B4 uh always the strongest
move we have Rook a to C8 and queen to
B3 now uh and now Rook F to E8 and it is
now as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game so The Rook on E8
although it looks a bit weird what is it
even doing there maybe you thought maybe
Rook to d8 but it's actually very well
placed here as if a central breakthrough
occurs the E file might open up and then
look at those Bishops on the E file so
The Rook is very well placed here uh you
could also put the Knight on f8 and go
to G6 you could also Play Bishop to f8
if needed to add additional support to
the king so it's a very nice move with
Rook F to D1 and now Queen to B8 sort of
finishing development here King to H1 uh
and now we have Pawn to H5 with King to
H1 uh this diagonal now becomes very
important and Candela goes for Pawn to
H5 she wants to play Pawn to H4 Pawn to
H3 and open up the white King's position
we have Bishop to F1 adding another
Defender here and H4 uh Queen to A2 and
now comes Knight to E5 now uh you you're
probably wondering if if H3 here is a
good move uh sure it can be played but
white can just block it with G3 she
could also play G4 and she could also
even capture queen queen to A2 might be
just signaling that that was her plan
because now she could place the queen to
G2 put the Rook on G1 and go after the
black king but also Queen to A2 kind of
says Okay I want to play Queen to F2 put
pressure on this diagonal put pressure
on B6 go Knight A4 really put pressure
on that B6 Pawn so also one of the
reasons why the queen is on A2 but uh
there's no need to rush things as uh I
mean you you have to win with black if
you want to become world champion so uh
you know better just to build up the
tension we have Knight to E5 and now
bosava goes for Knight to A4 preparing
to put more pressure on that B6 pawn and
now Bishop to d8 defending it now you
could also defend it with Bishop to A8
just so the queen defends but it's
better for a minor piece to defend the
pawn H and now Bishop to G5 now this is
a very problematic move as it attacks
the H4 pawn and it also defend attacks
the Knight now you might uh have some
ideas of Bishop captures and then the
bishop will not be able to capture uh
since you're going to pick up the pawn
here so maybe Candela will have to mess
up her Pawn structure in front of the
king so while you could play something
like Knight F to D7 so the bishop
defends and attacks and let's say the uh
this gets traded off and now the Knight
defends the B Pawn uh Candela says that
now it's time to stke she plays Pawn to
H3 and okay how do you how do you deal
with this uh one way is to play G
captures on H3 and we're going to show
it because it's actually a lot of fun
now uh the the whole position explodes
Pawn to B5 attacks the Knight here C
captures on B5 a captures Rook captures
on C8 Queen captures and now Bishop
captures on B5 attacking The Rook here
but now look at this Knight captures on
e4 and now what do you play of course
you have to you have to take the Rook or
you have to to take the bishop or you
have to take the Knight what do you play
here uh Believe It or Not uh best move
is Bishop captures on d8 and now the
idea was after Bishop captures Queen
captures now F captures on e4 and Bishop
captures on e4 and you would get this
position uh where Bellis would be up a
piece but Kela would have a very very
strong attack against the white king the
white King's defenses have been
completely uh destroyed you have a
knight and Bishop in the attack uh if
you find a way to get your rook and
queen into the attack could be very
nasty on the other hand if she defends
well then her two connected pass points
on the queen side should be enough to
decide the game so it's extremely
double-edged uh she's not interested in
that she goes for Bishop captures on F6
instead trying to win the pawn on B6
Bishop captures and now Knight captures
on B6 so she wins a pawn attacks The
Rook here Rook C to d8 and now Knight
back to A4 so uh what's the price of the
pawn well you will get um uh on the
attacking or rather on the defending
side of the this game H captures and G2
with check Bishop captures and now again
you don't have to rush anything Knight
to G6 preparing to get the Knight into
the game uh Queen to F2 it's very
important to uh include the queen into
the defense also you need to guard the
G3 and H four squares Bishop to E5 and
now Pawn to H3 we have Knight to E2 now
uh sorry Queen to C7 first uh here
Candela wants to get her Queen into the
game and um it'd be great if you could
get your queen all the way here plus you
had to play H3 as okay the Queen Bishop
battery here if um D5 is played would
really uh make problems for for the
white king So Queen C7 uh we have Knight
to E2 and now Knight to F4 offering a
trade of knights which B slva goes for
Knight captures Bishop captures and now
Rook to
C2 uh we have Rook to f8 now preparing
to open up the uh the the file for the
rook and look at this Bishop there this
is absolutely magnificent uh so Knight
to B2 it's also time to bring this
Knight back into the game uh Pawn to F5
now trying to open up the f file Knight
to D3 and F captures on e4 we have F
captures on e4 even allowing some
discoveries uh luckily there there
aren't any so Pawn to E5 first now when
you first saw this position I don't
think you ever imagined that this Pawn
would March forward everyone was
expecting this Pawn to March forward uh
but now this Pawn nicely defends the
bishop here and Bishop is just a monster
so Queen to E2 and now we have Bishop to
H6 now preparing to bring the Rooks over
to the file Rook to G1 basava also wants
to put pressure on the black king and
now Bishop to C8 putting pressure on the
H3 pawn pawn to C5 and now Rook to F6
defending and also maybe preparing to
double up here uh C captures on D6 Queen
captures and Knight to C5 and this is
now uh such a dangerous position you you
would not believe now uh here Bishop to
F4 was played which is uh objectively
the best move but just to show you what
what kind of a wild position it is let's
say you play Rook D to f8 you double up
here prepare to bring the queen to F2 uh
Rook to C3 preparing Rook to G3 now look
at this Rook F2 Queen to H5 and now even
Rook captures on G2 so you you have to
calculate all of this in order to uh to
actually decide for that Bishop to F or
move there and now if Rook captures on
G2 you will play Rook to F1 with check
and now you have two options Rook to G1
and King H2 if you go Rook to G1 then
just captures captures Queen to D4 check
will pick up the Rook here uh but after
the king moves Queen captures and C3 you
will uh face Queen to E8 check King to
H7 and queen captures and C8 check and
now after Queen to F3 check it will be a
draw even with the dark Square Bishop
there's just no way to H get it into the
game you King T1 and
okay if you allow Bishop to F5 check it
will be a draw and on the other hand
after Rook to F1 check if you don't
block you can play King to H2 uh but
then comes Bishop to F4 with check you
have to block with this rook and now
you're going to see a captures captures
and the king is actually very very safe
on G3 because again you are facing the
same issues this uh Queen uh queen queen
queen check um repetition will uh you
know prevent you from actually doing
anything here so while it is a very nice
idea uh remember she has to win this
game in order to win the championship so
she goes for Bishop to F4 the absolute
strongest move uh Rook to C3 and now
Rook to H6 now piling up on that poor H
H3 pawn and here we have Rook to D3 and
this is move 39 uh it's a most certainly
a critical position uh feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
what you would play here for black uh
while I give you a couple of
[Music]
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
the strong strongest objectively
strongest move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
congratulations on finding the Practical
strongest move the one that uh Candela
played here she played Queen captur on
D3 uh and now uh it's time to time to
really calculate and the only way to
defend this is to take with the queen
and give the queen back then you would
see Rook captures on D3 Knight captures
Bishop captures on H3 and now you're
going to play Knight captures on F4 e
captures and Bishop captures on H3 Rook
captures King G2 and Rook cap on A3 and
you have this position where you are
down upon in a rook end game but you
know with with perfect play you will be
able to defend this I still it will be
black playing for the win here however
after this uh Queen captures and D3 move
B played Knight captures and D3 and here
her position just falls apart entirely
uh Bishop captures on
H3 uh so you can't really not capture
otherwise you're just going to face you
know very very nasty discoveries so
Bishop captures an H 3 Rook captures on
H3 King to G2 and now Rook D captures on
D3 and now how do you play this okay uh
Queen and Rook versus two Rooks and the
bishop white um should be able to play
this but not with the white king being
so white in the open so Queen to A2 with
check King to h8 and now Queen to B1 but
now it is very very simple to convert
this Rook to C3 just going sorry not
Rook to C3 uh Rook to H2 check first and
after King to f one now comes Rook to C3
threatening Rook to C1 check to win the
White Queen and you can't really move
the White Queen away away from the back
rank otherwise Rook to C1 will be
Checkmate so she played A4 trying to get
some counterplay with a pass Pawn on the
queen side but there is no way to do
that The Rook C1 check Queen captures
Bishop captures uh Rook to G6 somehow
trying to get back into the game but now
Rook B2 putting the Rook behind the pass
Pawn uh Rook to B6 and now Bishop to D2
attacking the B4 for Pawn B5 a captures
and B5 a captures and Bishop to E3 and
Bishop to E3 is basically the final nail
in the coffin uh as now both the bishop
and The Rook control the B6 Square which
is a dark square and that means this
Pawn is never Crossing it so Rook to B8
check was played King to H7 now King E1
as there's nothing better and Here pawn
to G5 and he was in this position on
move 53 that bosava resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
you cannot push the pawn to B6 it's
covered by the bishop and by The Rook uh
so you can move the rook and lose the
pawn or you can just you know await a
few more moves until you are checkmated
also the queening square is covered by
the bishop so there is there is
literally zero counterplay here so uh
incredible stuff um like I said both of
them went into the final round without
losing a single game the entire
championship and now Bava you know this
is this is like the dream scenario of
the of a a World Chess Championship uh
you go into the final round being up a
full point you have the white pieces uh
but you know it also puts a lot of
pressure uh but okay uh Candela is the
uh was the favorite to win this and
maybe not to win this but she is the
favorite she's the second seed of the
tournament uh but Bas laava already drew
the top seat Karis so you know anything
can happen but here uh it was definitely
kandas day uh she she chose the the
perfect opening to play for the win uh
it's like Mikel tal said as he was also
um uh you know really big on on trying
out this asymmetrical openings like the
benon you know avoiding the D4 D5 stuff
uh he always said that if you if you
want to play for the win you have to
give your opponent some sort of um some
sort of an objective positional
advantage that can't really be converted
but it is considered an advantage and
then later on you will use those holes
that your opponent missed to uh take
advantage of the position not in those
exact words of course but something like
that
uh so yeah kandela Bell and Francisco gu
kamburu is the uh girls world junior
Championship under 20 years old uh she's
the the the fourth women's world
champion from Argentina and uh I mean
what an event what a spectacular final
round winning the winning the the game
and the championship with a queen
sacrifice I don't think you can you know
you cannot uh expect and want anything
more than that uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it and this
short coverage of the girls world junior
Championship I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to Jeff and I would like
to thank Robert araton Das Kumar K
Ingram and ber Berard Domani for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
day